overhead a telltale sign
just hours after moscow signed an
agreement with keeve to allow essential
grain shipments to leave odessa the key
black sea port came under fire
residents fearing for their lives
and plumes of smoke clearly visible
across the city the ukrainian military
says two russian caliber cruise missiles
hit buildings at the port and that its
air defenses brought down two
no significant damage was caused to the
port infrastructure the pump station was
hit it caught fire and the fire was
taken out
the ukrainian foreign ministry has
called the attack quote a spit in the
face of turkey and the united nations
which helped broker the shipping
agreement while the president has
condemned it
this after turkey and the u.n said
yesterday that they know how to
negotiate with russia and ensure
security a green corridor for the export
of ukrainian grain and not even 24 hours
had passed before the grain terminals
the territory of odessa and the port
were struck
but russia was quick to deny the attack
to turkey who helped broker the deal
less than 24 hours had passed since u.n
secretary general antonio gutierrez
praised the deal to open ukrainian ports
to commercial food exports as a beacon
of hope a deal to clear the way for the
shipment of millions of tons of
ukrainian grain and some russian exports
of grain and fertilizer held up by the
war
ukraine is one of the world's largest
exporters of wheat corn and sunflower
oil but russia's invasion and blockade
of its ports halted shipments a holdup
that has exposed countries around the
world especially in africa and the
middle east to the threat of a food
crisis
i think the other factor here is that
there are a lot of neighboring countries
egypt for example which russia has
fairly good relationships with and
that's those are exactly the countries
that have really been suffering from the
increase in grain prices bread prices
things like that so
i don't think russia wants to make
itself look like the bad guy on the
block earlier this week russia announced
it was broadening the scope of its
military operation in ukraine that
suggests peace is a long way off what
remains
is the specter of a global food crisis
that could cause unrest in other
countries alan fisher al jazeera ukraine